i i i zombie finished and then it's the
you know
can you make magic happen again and book
another role can you book roll number
two because that lasted for five years
right um and i was terrified uh you're
terrified of what
not having a show of what's next what's
next where do i go you saved your money
and you know you
you didn't
i thought i i i went mental are you a
partier i was you were a partier when
you say party drugs alcohol not drugs i
was never really uh on the drug scene i
i'd never lived away from home and i'd
never really had disposable income and a
zombie
shot in vancouver i've been up in
vancouver and it's raining all the time
and it's grace guys as you know which
probably get prompted you to drink
it did
it did it did it does and it's it's yeah
it's super privileged problems i get it
but you know
it what turned into like uh blow off
steam friday turns into a
tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday
so you could you drink a lot heavily
heavily every day yeah like how what's
heavily like what's one day of drinking
i mean it wasn't like
eight beers oh no it would have been
like
uh
i would do half a bottle of
jameson
half a bottle
and then like
vodka sodas
along you can drink that much i was at
that time i'm a lightweight now and
you're like 32 at this point yeah i was
between 28 and yeah 28 and 33 was dude
and you could still learn all your lines
do all your [ __ ] come prepared be a pro
i couldn't keep the weight off though i
now get nervous if it's a late night
snack i'm like
i don't want to have this at night i
don't want to almost die yeah
how how did you quit the drinking or or
how did you slow down how did you stop
doing five days a week i zombie stopped
i zombie you stopped it for the work
as soon as the show was over it stopped
i've never drank like that since what so
what do you what was the meaning behind
drinking being alone being in vancouver
being alone being in vancouver being on
that show dealing with work politics
uh you were depressed yeah you were
depressed and the alcohol was uh blowing
off steam partying just partying and i
wasn't like an arc i didn't feel like i
was an alcoholic i didn't have a problem
but then i don't know you look back at
it and you're like [ __ ] now we used
to polish off a lot of drinks yeah you
know and then you know this and i
started hearing back the stories about
things i did or places i went and i'm
like
bad parts of town you didn't go to
hastings did you i went to hastings yeah
that's a rough area oh yeah it's a super
rough area you got to be careful
in the hastings yeah
yeah but yeah it just it went with the
job early on you said you're an
emotional person
what does that mean
what kind of emotions are are you
someone that cries a lot yeah you do cry
a lot everything really every emotion so
you you get angry often yep in the same
day as crying so you could lose your
[ __ ] one day and cry yeah and be happy
really and have the best day do you do
you like that about yourself or is it
something that you're working on so you
can control that
i i don't like it you're like i don't
know because like does it does it work
for you is it
i i haven't
figured it out yet because
my mum will tell you
that i've always been like that as a kid
just extremities of emotion and then i i
did need therapy after i zombie and i
tried therapy for the first time and
it felt cliched
really oh yeah well it felt cliche to do
it because i was like of course of
course you now live in la
and you're a little london boy and
you're sitting there going i think my
grandad was this and like so if it took
a while for me to feel
and i felt like i was
i was doing some really weird [ __ ] in
therapy i was so self-aware
i felt like i was bullshitting yeah
i felt like i was on in an interview
you're making them like you yeah i was i
haven't done that where you're just like
yeah you know i don't have a problem
with that no yeah you know it's like so
what are you up to this weekend what'd
you do this isn't this is about you
this is about making you better this is
about getting all your demons out yeah
and once you can sort of relax into it
and stop that [ __ ] and the truth
starts to come out that's when it's
therapeutic yeah i never got to that
part you never got to that part no i was
still in the performing get trying to
get validation waiting for the therapist
to be like well i've seen your work and
you're a fantastic actor
you're very handsome
and i felt like i was
just trying to manipulate therapy and
but what came from it
was
a mild form of a diagnosis of bipolar
wow